tutto ciò che un uomo riesce ad
immaginare altri uomini sapranno
realizzarlo in questa frase c'è la
perfetta sintesi di quello che la
ricerca di esopianeti ha rappresentato
negli ultimi trent'anni fino a 30 anni
fa noi conoscevamo solamente i pianeti
del sistema solare
quando io parlo di esopianeti o pianeti
extrasolari mi riferisco a pianeti che
stanno al di là del sistema solare
attorno a stelle diverse dal sole
l'uomo ha sempre cercato fin
dall'antichità tracce di possibili nuovi
mondi e soprattutto tracce di possibile
vita oltre a quella presente sulla terra
questa è una domanda che ci siamo posti
tutti io per prima siamo soli
nell'universo
l'avrete fatto anche voi io sono sempre
stata appassionata di astronomia
dell'osservazione delle stelle
costellazioni luna e da ragazzina ero
affascinata da una serie tv spazio 1999
che raccontava la vita di un gruppo di
astronauti che rimanevano intrappolati
sulla base lunare alpha dopo che la luna
era uscita dalla sua orbita e aveva
cominciato a vagare nel vuoto
bene in questo pagare senza meta
venivano a contatto con civiltà aliene
che talvolta erano amichevoli talvolta
ostili e vedevano nuovi pianeti e forme
di vita insolita
quindi io come tutti i ragazzini
dell'epoca volevo diventare astronauta
poi però ho avuto sempre più spesso la
visione di me adulta che lavoravano i
più grandi telescopi del mondo ad
osservare le stelle e soprattutto a
scoprire nuovi pianeti
questa visione si è realizzata perché io
sono diventato astrofisico
e sono responsabile di un programma
internazionale per la ricerca di pianeti
attorno a stelle rosse che sono stelle
più piccole e più fredde del sole e io
ho il privilegio di frequentare molti
dei telescopi che si trovano sull'isola
di la palma alle canarie e in particolar
modo il telescopio nazionale galileo che
il telescopio italiano con cui noi
facciamo le nostre osservazioni per il
nostro programma proprio analizzando
queste osservazioni recentemente ho
scoperto tre pianeti attorno a due
stelle rosse questi pianeti sono delle
super terre le super terre sono dei
pianeti terrestri come la terra massicci
un po più massicci della terra da 2 a 10
masse terrestri è una tipologia di
pianeta che non esiste nel nostro
sistema solare
ma noi oggi sappiamo che è molto diffuso
nell'universo e appunto se vogliamo
rispondere alla domanda ma quanti sono i
pianeti esistenti quanti sono i pianeti
dell'universo
beh la la risposta più corretta e sono
tanti quante sono le stelle nella nostra
galassia la via lattea si stima che ci
siano mille miliardi di stelle è più o
meno lo stesso numero di galassie
nell'universo visibile quindi possiamo a
buon diritto dire che i pianeti sono
ovunque ma se i pianeti sono ovunque e
l'uomo li cerca da tanto tempo
dall'antichità perché abbiamo cominciato
a parlare di pianeti extrasolari
solamente negli ultimi 30 anni della
nostra storia
beh perché la ricerca di pianeti
extrasolari è sempre stata condizionata
dall uso degli strumenti adatti per
tutto il xix secolo è stato un
susseguirsi di annunci di scoperte che
sono state puntualmente
perché gli strumenti a disposizione per
quell'epoca non avevano la precisione la
stabilità necessarie per poterle
confermare quindi i pianeti erano
oggetti piccoli troppo lontani troppo
vicini a la stella madre una sorgente
estremamente luminosa e dobbiamo
riflettere sul fatto che tutto quello
che conosciamo nell'universo noi lo
conosciamo grazie alla luce che arriva
fino a noi
e allora la domanda è ma se la i pianeti
sono degli oggetti scuri e piccoli se si
perdono nella luce della stella madre
che è troppo vicina come facciamo noi a
trovarli a vederli
ebbene il pianeta c'è noi non siamo in
grado di vederlo però lascia delle
tracce intorno a sé in particolare un
pianeta per quanto piccolo provoca degli
effetti gravitazionali sulla stella
attorno a cui orbita
quindi se c'è un pianeta in orbita la
stella non rimarrà ferma ma si muoverà
avvicinandosi allontanandosi da noi
osservatori che ne raccogliamo la luce e
analizzando la luce vediamo le tracce di
questi piccoli spostamenti per capire il
moto di un sistema pianeta stella
possiamo fare un'analogia molto semplice
un gioco tra un adulto e un bambino che
si tengono con entrambe le mani e
ruotano uno intorno all'altro se la
mossa del bambino è molto piccola lo
spostamento che provoca sull'adulto sarà
trascurabile quanto più massiccio e il
bambino tanto maggiore sarà lo
spostamento che provoca sull'adulto la
stessa cosa succede con i pianeti tanto
più massiccio è il pianeta è tanto più
vicino alla stella madre tanto maggiore
sarà la perturbazione che provocherà sul
moto della stella
e quindi tanto più misurabile sarà
questo piccolo spostamento il metodo che
è stato utilizzato per scoprire il primo
pianeta extrasolare è basato sulle
effetto doppler
forse il nome a voi non dice niente però
è un effetto che voi tutti conoscete xkè
lo stesso effetto che si verifica quando
c'è un'ambulanza che si avvicina o si
allontana quando l'ambulanza si avvicina
noi osservatori saremo raggiunti da onde
di alta frequenza e quindi sentiremo un
suono più acuto quando l'ambulanza si
allontana saremo raggiunti da onde di
bassa frequenza e quindi sentire un
suono più grave la stessa cosa possiamo
dirla per le stelle i pianeti in
particolare quindi la stella è la nostra
ambulanza e la luce e il suono che ci
arriva dalla sirena quando la stella si
muove verso di noi nella nostra
direzione
noi saremo raggiunti da onde di alta
frequenza e noi diciamo che la luce sarà
spostata verso il blu quando la stella
si allontana da noi saremo raggiunti da
onde di bassa frequenza ossia la luce
spostata verso il rosso
analizzando la luce che raccogliamo
dalla stella possiamo trovare le tracce
di questi spostamenti
se però questi spostamenti sono
periodici e quindi c'è un avvicinarsi
allontanarsi avvicinarsi a loro sappiamo
che c'è un corpo che non riusciamo a
vedere ma che è in orbita attorno alla
stella 1952 il primo che ipotizzò di
poter usare l'effetto doppler per
scoprire pianeti e fu un astronomo russo
americano 8 struve la precisione degli
strumenti in quel periodo era di 1.000
metri al secondo
un km al secondo è abbastanza per
scoprire pianeti questa precisione
vi porto ai bordi del sistema solare per
farvi capire di che ordine di grandezza
stiamo parlando
un pianeta gigante come giove provoca
sul sole uno spostamento di 12 metri al
secondo
un pianeta come saturno uno spostamento
di 2,7 metri al secondo mentre la terra
che è un pianeta piccolo provoca uno
spostamento di 10 centimetri al secondo
è inimmaginabile pensare di poter
misurare queste variazioni con quella
precisione di un km al secondo quindi
struve aveva immaginato un metodo quando
ancora gli strumenti a disposizione non
avevano assolutamente la precisione per
poter fare questo tipo di misure
bisognava aspettare però qualcuno dopo
di lui accettò la sua eredità e comincio
a pensare alla possibilità di creare
degli strumenti sempre più precisi 1995
la scoperta del primo pianeta
extrasolare attorno ad una stella di
tipo sole ad opera degli astronomi
svizzeri maggiore che lo 51 pegasi b è
il nome di questa di questo pianeta ed è
un gioviano caldo quindi un pianeta
gigante come giove ma si trova a
distanza ravvicinata dalla stella madre
e diciamo a un decimo della distanza di
mercurio dal sole
ora il pianeta venne subito chiamato il
pianeta impossibile perché per l'unico
paradigma esistente in quel periodo cioè
il sistema solare non si pensava che un
pianeta del genere un gigante si potesse
formare a distanze così ravvicinate
dalla stella madre
semplicemente perché a quelle distanze
non esiste abbastanza materiale da poter
formare un pianeta
noi oggi sappiamo che giuliani caldi
sono molto diffusi è una tipologia di
pianeta che non esiste nel nostro
sistema solare e molto probabilmente non
si formano lì si formano molto distanti
e poi successivamente migrano verso
l'interno
la precisione dello strumento con cui è
stato scoperto il primo pianeta era di
15 metri al secondo
quindi con questo strumento si potevano
trovare i giganti come effettivamente
successo
mancavano ancora i pianeti piccoli ma
non perché non esistono ma semplicemente
perché provocano delle perturbazioni
talmente piccole che non possono essere
misurate vi faccio un esempio che ho
sentito recentemente che assolutamente
calzante se noi andiamo a pescare con
una rete a maglie larghe
noi prenderemo pesci grandi ma non
perché pesci piccoli non esistono ma
perché sfuggono
se noi diminuiamo le dimensioni delle
maglie noi prenderemo anche i pesci più
piccoli ed è quello che è successo con
gli esopianeti 1996 è servito un solo
anno per passare dalla precisione di 15
metri al secondo a 3 metri al secondo
2003 otto anni dalla prima scoperta si
arriva ad una precisione di inferiore a
un metro al secondo quindi c'è stato un
progresso tecnologico enorme quindi io
vi ho detto che non è possibile trovare
pianeti di tipo terra attorno a stelle
di tipo sole con questi strumenti mai
possibile trovare pianeti di tipo terra
quindi pianeti piccoli attorno a stelle
più piccole del sole perché a parità di
pianeta se la stella è più piccola
le perturbazioni causate da quel pianeta
saranno più grandi e quindi saranno più
facilmente misurabili 2006 2009 il
lancio di piccoli telescopi spaziali
eliminando il rumore dovuto
all'atmosfera terrestre permette di
scoprire una valanga di pianeti perché
permette l'osservazione di un gran
numero di stelle per tempi molto lunghi
e in maniera continua in che modo
grazie al transito del pianeta davanti
al disco della stella che provoca una
mini eclisse quindi fa diminuire la
luminosità della stella in particolare
con questo metodo tanto più massiccio è
il pianeta tanto maggiore sarà l'effetto
che noi riusciremo a misurare bene noi
oggi conosciamo migliaia di pianeti dal
95 ad oggi ne abbiamo scoperti più di 4
mila e più di 3.000 sistemi planetari e
diciamo che abbiamo visto tutti i tipi
di pianeti possibili esistono pianeti
che orbitano attorno a due soli come
quanto previsto nel film guerre stellari
esistono pianeti che evaporano pianeti
che sono ricoperti completamente da
oceani e queste per citare solo alcuni
esempi delle più diverse più strane
tipologie di pianeti che stiamo vedendo
la fuori 2018 e la storia di oggi si
raggiunge la precisione di 10 centimetri
al secondo quindi noi oggi possiamo
trovare pianeti di tipo terra attorno a
stelle di tipo sole la storia della
ricerca di esopianeti è l'esempio di
come partendo da un'idea plausibile sia
stato possibile sviluppare la tecnologia
superare limiti teorici tecnologici per
arrivare alla realizzazione di questa
idea è una cosa importantissima è che se
gli astronomi del xix secolo ventesimo
secolo si fossero arresi
se avessero detto bene quest'idea e
straordinaria trovare pianeti però
rimane tutto teorico perché non abbiamo
gli strumenti adatti per porte per
poterli trovare bene oggi noi non
saremmo qui
sicuramente non sa parlare di esopianeti
parleremo solo dei pianeti del sistema
solare e questa è una cosa importante
della scienza a porsi delle mete
ambiziose e lavorare per raggiungerle e
superarle
e questo non vale solo per la scienza
vale per tutti i campi vale per la vita
perché se uno ha un'idea in cui crede
fermamente e che vuole raggiungere se
rinuncia ha già perso questo quindi
questa è la storia di
superamento di limiti con percorsi che
non erano mai stati tracciati prima
noi sappiamo che lì fuori e pieno di
pianeti e sicuramente c'è anche la terra
2.0
probabilmente più di una con forme di
vita come la conosciamo noi o anche
inimmaginabili al momento per noi
io oggi posso dire che tutto ciò che un
uomo ha immaginato altri uomini hanno
realizzato perché noi oggi sappiamo
esattamente dove dobbiamo guardare come
dobbiamo guardare ma questa non è la
fine della storia perché in questo campo
siamo solo all'inizio e davanti a noi ci
sono grandissime avventure per me che
sono ricercatore ma anche perché ho la
passione per l'astronomia e
entusiasmante vedere che la realtà che
stiamo osservando con gli esopianeti è
talvolta molto più fantasiosa della
migliore letteratura di fantascienza
[Applauso]
[Musica]